よろしくお願いします
えっと 悟りについての第3番目の講義でございます
でもう一回あるようなんですけど
あの これはまあ いくらお話しても終わりきれない問題なんですね
えーと 今日はね いくらかこのこの一回目で話しましたけど
一回目ですごく努力したのは
このなぜ悟るかという
この悟りそのものを正当化しようと
悟らなくてはならないと
まあ正当化しようということで必死になって喋りましたけど
でも あの この私たちのこの正当論というのは
普通の論理とは違いますから
それ私たちって言ったらちょっと大げさなんですけど
まあお釈迦様のまあ正当論というのはやっぱり少々違いますので
まあおそらくこれで悟りっていいものかというふうに納得いかなかった可能性もあります
で なぜならば この悟りというものは
この普通 老工ってという言葉で表現しているんですね
老工って 老化っていうのは世界のことを
世間のこと うってれっていうのは乗り越えているということで
これは日本仏教用語で出世間的というふうな言葉があるんですね
ですから 出世間的なものであると
ですから この世の中にはなんか関係ないものように感じてしまうんですね
ですから 私は これは世間の次元を超越しているというふうに訳したいんですね
そこで問題は じゃあ他の宗教と何が変わりますかということなんですね
で そこで世間というのはどういうものかと
また仏教の定義が違うんですね
仏教では神々の次元であろうか
もっと上の次元であろうか
いかなり いかなる生命であろうか
それはすべて世間という言葉に
入れてしまうんですね
たとえ神になって まあそういや
一般的な理解でよろしいですけど
たとえ人が神になってしまっても
まあどんな状態になってしまっても
やっぱりそれは世間だと
ですから そこで定義が変わってしまっちゃうんですね
すべての次元を超越するという言葉です
それで一般的には 人々にはまあなくてもいいんじゃないかなということが出てくるんですね
それだったら そういうことで
私はこの世の中に我々持っているすべての価値観をじゃあ壊してみようと
それはまあ 私はそういう努力をしたんだけど
それお釈迦様はそういうふうに経典の中で
まあ人間ありがたいと思っている一切の価値というのは
何て言いますかね 考え直してるんですね
これ否定しているわけでもなく
肯定しているわけでもなく
まあ考え直してみましょうと
そこで出てくる結論は
まあすべてのものはものすごい速さで変化していくんだと
それから ある実体としてものがあるわけではありませんと
いつでもいろんな原因条件揃ったところで現象が成り立つのみですよと
ですから どこにでも実体あるんじゃなくて
その瞬間だけ存在する現象だけですよという言葉によって価値観は消えてしまうんですね
だからそこら辺は考え方はもう結構難しいと思います
なぜならば 悟りというのは長い間の修行の結果として得られるものだから
まあ聞いただけでよく分かったということにはならないんですね
ですから このまあ 少々苦労していただいて
理解してほしい論理なんです
はい 全てのものはそれ物として存在しないんですね
瞬間の出来事 そこで仏教ではこの稲妻に例えているんですね
稲妻っていうのは瞬間現れて消えてしまうんですね
ずっと光っているわけではありません
で そこで何か我々に捕まえる実体がありますかというと
そこで何か捕まえる実体ではありません
で 科学的 いわゆる仏教の科学的なんですけど
厳密に科学的に考えちゃうと
なぜ稲妻だけ瞬間に変化して消えていくんですかね
他のものは固定しているんですかね
そんなことはありえないんだと
普通に考えてみましょう
稲妻もこの宇宙の物質の一つの現象であって
我々も宇宙の物質のほんの一部と言えないんですからね
ものひとかけらで塵にもあわない値しないぐらいの
ほんのちょっとのもので
ですから なぜ稲妻だけ瞬間に消えてしまって
私はもうずっと永久的に永遠にいられるんだと思えるんでしょうかと
もしものに本来的な法則があるならば
そこは稲妻と同じで瞬間に消えていくんではないかと
だからわざとこのずっと長生きしている人に向かって
あなたは瞬間瞬間変化しているんですよというふうにことを言うんではなくて
それをあなたは心きれいにして
自分のことを観察してみなさいと
そうすると 自分が瞬間瞬間変化して変わっていくんだということをわかるはずですよと
そういうことを取ると
価値はなくなっちゃうんですね
私がいて 私の息子がいるとする
私がいるという私は 瞬間瞬間変わって変わって違う私になってしまっちゃうし
私の息子だというところでも
その息子も瞬間瞬間変わって違うものになってしまっちゃうし
でも我々に心の中では
その変わっていく関係の中で
いろんな憎しみも苦しみも欲も怒りもありとあらゆる感情が生まれてきて
その悪い感情だけ流れていって大変苦しみを味わっている
もし物事は瞬間瞬間に変化していくんだということ
自分も物事全ては瞬間瞬間変化していくんだということをわかると
そこに心の偉大なる安らぎが生まれるんだと
その心に現れる偉大なる安らぎが悟りというんですね
普通は心にはものすごい我々
すごい重り荷物 持ってるんです
心は硬いんです 重いんです
で いろんな責任感があったりして
あれやらなくてはいけない
これやらなくてはいけないとか
いろんなことがあったりして
自分の体に対して 社会関係に対して
いろんなものに対して
我々の心の中ですごい重い責任感があったりする
それによって人間というのはすごくストレスを感じたりする
自由に行動できなくなったりもする
その心のこのものすごい重い荷物が消えてしまうんですね
そういうことで 悟らないよりは悟りを開いた方がまあ楽じゃないかなと
ですから 悟りを本当にきちんとした知識的に正当化しなくちゃいけないんだから
知識的に世の中の人々のこのやっている生き方っていうのは
まあ無知的で それほど思うほど意味がないんだとということを言っただけなんです
そこはすごい力強く言わないと
悟りというところまではいかないんですね
例えば軽々く やっぱりそういう今頃人々がやっていることはね
大した意味がないんだと
それぐらい言ったっても
じゃあだから悟りましょうというところまではいけないんですね
じゃあなんとかならないんですかと
もっと社会はもっと意味ある社会に変えられませんか？と
例えば 我々の欲的な生き方によって生きている
この地球は環境を破壊してしまったんだと
じゃあどうしましょうか
なんとかなりませんか？というふうに考えちゃうんですね
だから悟りましょうというふうには考えません
じゃあみんな自然を大事にしましょう
地球を守りましょうという答えには行くんですね
ですから 私はそこら辺はすごく極力的に
人類はね 地球は大事にするわけじゃないんだぞ
あんた方何やったっても
自分生きてる土台を破壊するんだと
じゃあ頑張ってみてくださいという調子で喋ってるんですね
だから人類が現れたその日からも地球は破壊してきたのではないかと
今更何とかしようと思ったっても
結局結果は同じですよと
そうするとお手上げ状態なんですね
そのお手上げ状態から
まあ悟りの世界を話したかったんです
だから 家族にしたっても
仕事にしたっても 私たちは元気で健康的で
おいしい食べ物を食べて長生きしましょうといういろんな人間の価値観がありまして
私はそれは徹底的に壊してしまって
お手上げ状態に心を持ってきたかったんですね
そういうこというと もうどうしようもないんではないかと
そうですよと 悟るしか方法ないんだと
脱出するしか方法ないんだと
超越するしか方法ないんだというふうな調子では話してたんで
その話し方がもう大変
この 強力すぎなんです
ですから 昔 お釈迦様も説法する場合は
相手の顔を見て 相手が宗教家で長い間修行している人であるならば
この修行の世界 仏教であろうがどんな宗教だろうか
あまり仏教の世界は気にしないんです
長い間修行してきた人であるならば
その人はとっくに世間に対する欲をもう捨てているんですね
捨てて真理を求めて頑張っているんですね
だから 普通の人と違って
この修行をやっている
なさっている方々は まあそれなりにまあレベルが違うと
そういう人々にはいきなり言って
解脱の世界を言ってしまう
そこでどんどんお釈迦様にもこの善人が来て質問するということはもう少なくなってしまったんです
なぜかというと 世の中で優れている善人というのはたくさんいるわけじゃないんです
一人 二人  3人ぐらいですね
ですから お釈迦様にはどんどん話を聞きに来たのは普通の方々
普通の仕事をして 家を守って
商売をして生活する人々
その人々は家のことは心配いっぱいあるし
収入がなくなったらどうしようかという心配もあるし
子供が病気になったらどうしますかということもあるし
いろいろ日常世界の一杯心配事はあるんですね
で その人にとっていきなり全ては無意味ですよと言っても
それは理解しないんです
全ては無意味でした 自分の赤ちゃん捨てるんですかねというふうな
赤ちゃんが病弱で もう一日ごとに熱を出しているんだと
だからすごい苦しんでいるんだという場合
まあ無意味ですよと言ったら
そこは話合わないんですね
でもそんな話をお釈迦様がしたわけではないんです
そこでお釈迦様は次に取った手段はアヌプッビーカタという手段なんですね
アヌプッビーカタ アヌプッビーっていうのは
この段階的というか 徐々にというかね
英語で言えばグラジュアルですね
すごくわかりやすいところから
ほんのちょっとほんのちょっと
じゃあここまでわかったならば
次にこういうことを理解しましょうと
これをわかったならば
こういうことを理解しましょうと
そういうふうに このアヌプッビーカタという方向へ
お釈迦様は自分の説法を変えるんですね
で 皆様 日本語でよく読まれている経典がありますね
中村元先生訳しているブッダの言葉でしたっけ？真理の言葉でしたっけ
ああいうのはアヌプッビーカタではありません
あれは特にスッタニパータというのは
いきなり大変怖い この真理の世界語だったものなんですね
だからそれは中村先生っていうのはものすごい大なる先生だから
これは誰にでも読んでわかるように大変な才能を発揮して訳しているんです
なかなかあれほど現代日本語に訳できる能力はある
いっぱい日本訳ありますけど
パーリ聖典のね でもあれほどわかりやすく
またぴったしと だから私は原文と比べてみるんだからね
まあよくこういう言葉を選んで訳しているなと感心するばっかりですけどね
で そういうふうな読みやすいんだからといって
皆様はいきなりそういうところを読んで
いろいろまあどうかなと私は思いますけど
あれはあれ 一般的にわかるように書いているだけで
原文で読んで ここでどんな意味あるかというと
大変な強力なんです 例えばスッタニパータというのは真理の言葉ですね
訳してタイトルは そちらに 1番目の経典経典にしたっても
人間と何の関係も持つなと
社会とは 全部捨てなさいと
面倒くさいんだと 関係あるということは
もうあなたは大変苦しんでいることやと
だから 犀の角のごとくで
犀のごとくですか 一人で生きろ
生きていなさいと それだけの行みだっても
社会そのものに反対的なことを言っているんですね
はっきり言うと 人間というのは社会
社会作って生きてる動物でしょう
生き物でしょうし 壊せと
だからそこは理解できるわけじゃないんです
あれはこの徹底的に哲学的に真理を探求して
探求して探求して もう究極的に真理を探している人が壁にぶつかったところで言ってる答えなんですね
ですから 一般の方々には
そこはね そんなに関係あるかどうか
私はちょっと疑問に思うんですね
そういうわけでお釈迦様は次の手段として
もう善人たちが終わりましたし
それから出てきたのは
僕みたいにもう頭も悪い
真面目に何にもやらない
もう弟子たちばっかりなんですね
言うことは聞かないし
頑張れなさいと言っても
はい わかりましたと言って頑張らないし
だからどうしようもない人々を
我々みたいな人々はどんどんどんどん
もう何百人も集めて 大勢に集めて
もう話を聞くんですね
そこでいきなり全部捨てろとかいう話はなかったんですね
そこでアヌアヌプビー方という手段に
徐々に段階的に心のレベルを持っていけるように話しましょうと
で それから仏教の知識ある方々はよく知ってるんですね
お釈迦様は全てのことはドッカですよと
苦しみですよというふうにおっしゃったこと
一切は苦しみ 空ですよと
なんか暗いんではないかと
でも アヌプビー方の場合は
この一切は空であるというふうには話はしません
アヌプビー方の場合は
お釈迦様のとった手段は
じゃあこれから幸福の道を教えますと
これから人はどうすれば幸せになるかと教えますと
どうすれば幸福に 幸せに
楽しくなりますかと ということで
すごく誰にでもわかりやすい幸せの定義から
どんどんどんどん高いレベルの幸せの定義まで話を続けるんです
それで我々よく知っている
喧嘩するなかれと 喧嘩したら苦しいでしょうと
怒ってはいけませんと
まあ時々人々がね まあ財産なくなって
ものすごい精神的にショックを受けて
いたらね まあ財産はいいことですけどね
あまりあなたはあまりにもそれは自分のものだと
自分から逃げないものだと思っていたんだから
その苦しみは受けているんだと
そんなものはまあ出たり入ったりするものだからね
もう立ち直ってくださいと
また頑張ればいいんじゃないんですかと
そういうところから始まるんです
話は ですから この幸福になる道として一番最初に出てくるのは布施のお話
で 布施のお話っていうのはもう大変わかりやすいんです
このお布施っていうのは
このいろいろこの人々が言っているように
まあ何かお金あげた それだけで終わったという話ではなくて
仏教の布施っていうのは福祉という意味も入ってあって
それから人間の社会の一員だから
社会の中に平和で幸せで生きるためには必ずしも必要であること
いわゆる他人を助けるならば
自分を助けられる 協調
調和 それは布施なんですね
お金がない人にお金あげる
ご飯がない人いるならば
ご飯もあげる 慰めてほしい人がいるならば
その人を慰めてあげる
励ましてほしい 欲しい
励ます必要ある人がいるならば
励ましてあげる 自分だけじゃないんだと
私 私一人で偉そうに勝手に生きているのではないんだと
みんなのおかげで生きているんだという意味でお布施なんです
お布施っていうのは このギフトあげるという意味なんですけど
原文は訳するとね 貢献する
で 何か自分が他人に貢献すると
あなたはすごく楽しいでしょうと
心は充実感なるでしょうと
生きることは虚しく感じないでしょうと
それで危険がなくなるでしょうと
社会からあなたを批判することも
あなたの足を引っ張ることもどんどんなくなるでしょうと
それによってあなたは豊かになるんだと
社会の人々はあなたに対して大変親切な優しい気持ちであなたのことを見ているならば
あなたには商売もうまくいくんだと
農業はうまくいくんだと
で 昔は王様でしたから
王様は勝手にあなたの財産を奪おうとはしないんだと
今風に言えばもう税金ですけどね
それで楽でしょうと そうやって長い時間かけてこの貢献するということ
それですよと 幸せな道は
まず説得させるんですね
そこで仏教というのは神秘的な迷信的なことを言えませんだから
このちゃんとお祈りしていますかとかね
そういうことは使わないんですね
その代わりに貢献しましょうと
貢献される相手は人間だけじゃないんですね
自分の家族だけじゃないんですね
動物も自然にも どちらにでも自分には何か貢献できることがあるんだと
そこを頑張ってみたらどうですかと
社会に貢献することによって
あなたは社会に認められる
社会に自分の居場所が出来上がっちゃうんだと
家に貢献しないと家から追い出されるでしょ
我々はいくら家庭を作っていても
家庭に何も貢献しないと追い出されちゃうんです
それで不幸になるでしょうに
ですから 家庭に貢献すると幸せになるならば
なぜ限りなく貢献の精神を育てないんですかと
そういう話は論理的で
またわかりやすくて また事実でもありますね
その中にお釈迦様はずっともう一つ理解しにくい真理も持っていくんです
で それは因果法則なんですね
いわゆる何かものがあるということは
そのものを成り立っている条件
原因はちゃんとそろっていないといけないんですね
だから あなたは幸福になりたいと思うならば
その幸福になれる原因
ちゃんとそろっておきましょうと
それで原因そろわなくちゃいけないんだから
自分で管理できるところだけ喋るんですね
台風やめましょうとかね
トルネードをやめましょうとかは言わないんです
あんた方は頑張って地震が起こらないようにしましょうという話はないんです
それは人間にコントロールできる世界じゃないんです
そういうわけで もう神々を持ってこないんですね
神様の気持ち次第ですよと
恵まれているか恵まれてないかっていうのは
それは仏教は否定するんです
あなたは恵まれているか
恵まれてないかということは
あなたの行為次第ですよと
あなたは優しい人間にいたならば恵まれているんだと
だからどんな悪い人にも
どんな悪人にでも もうちょっと頭を洗って考えると
悪行は良くないんだと
わがままは良くないんだと
自分本位は良くないんだと
それでは 自分も楽しくはないし
他人にも迷惑をかけているんだということをわかるでしょうし
だから たとえ悪人でも
このお釈迦様の話は実践できるんですね
実行できるんです 恵まれてない人に言って
まあそれはもう神様決まったことだからね
あんた落ち着きなさいという話はしませんね
で 言われて落ち着く方々いるんだけど
僕らみたいな このすごく
あの 何といいますか 糸を切られた凧のように考えるように育てられた場合は納得いかないんですね
それでも何ですかと この不幸はと納得いかない
それであなたの心次第ですよと
あなたの考え方次第ですよと
あなたの行為次第ですよと言ったら
あ そう じゃあいい行為してみますと
もっと親切な人間になってみますと
いうふうに自分でコントロールできるんですね
そうやってそれはお布施の話なんです
ですから この皆様 伝統的に知っているお布施の概念とはずいぶん違うかもしれません
で 仏教ではこの何といいますか
かなりこれ大きなスケールで考えているんですね
何でもかなり大きい宇宙的なスケールで考えちゃうんですね
だから ある経典にあるんですね
いいことをする人は心でも大変喜んでいるんだと
イダ・モーデティ 亡くなってもその人は楽しいんだと
ペッチャ・モーデティ
カタプンニョをウバヤットモーデティと
徳を積む人はどちらでも楽しく生活するんだと
大変楽しいんだと で そういう次元の話はだいたいわかりやすい
それでお布施の話だけでもかなり時間かかりますよ
それは人間というのはわがままだから
自分だけ良ければいいと思っているんだから
それ説得することは大変なことなんです
でも 長い間の仏教 仏教の修行をやめても
ただ布施というその一つの概念だけ理解しても
偉大なる人物になることだけは確かなんですね
なぜならば 自分というこの殻を破って
自分一人で生きているんじゃないんだと
誰に見ても この人のおかげで
この人のおかげで この動物たちのおかげで
この植物のおかげで 生きているんだと
自分が借りてるばっかしですよと
自我が消えるでしょうに
わがままにならないでしょうに
で 他人に迷惑をかける人間にはならないんですね
ですから その その概念したっても偉大
ものすごい偉大なる哲学なんです
でも 社会の次元で喋ってるんだから
一応実行するかしないかにかかわらず
理解ぐらいはできるんですね
理解したっても何の得もないんです
やっぱり実行してみなきゃ
まあその人は自分の幸福をつかまるんですね
それ終わったところでお釈迦様は次のステップに行くんですね
じゃああなたは布施行為によって幸福をつかまりますと
でも あなた自身の心は
よく怒るんだったら 性格が悪いんだったら
いくら人助けてもいるでしょうね
人助けるんだけど 性格は荒っぽいと
乱暴だと 人助けはするんだけど
よく怒るんだと あんた方を助けているのではないかと
結局 性格によって人助けはどんどん人いじめに変わっちゃうんです
お母さんたちがいるでしょ
もう時々子供虐待する
全然お母さんが子供を虐待したくないんです
でもそうやってしまっちゃうと
ですから 子供を育てたいんです
子供のことをちゃんと面倒見てあげたいんですけど
知らないうちにもう虐待してしまう
この虐待という形にならなくても
かなり子供の精神をいじめているんです
で そこでちょっとレベル高い厳密なところにお釈迦様は話を続けていくんですね
そこは何ですかと あなたはいいことをしようとしたのに
いい結果が得られなかったと
子供は立派に育てようとしたのに
としては子供はもう悪くなってしまったと
家族のために頑張ったんだけど
家族は不幸になってしまったと
それは何でしょうかと
ということは 布施行為だけでは幸せは安定しませんと
もう一つあるんだと それは道徳的な生き方なんですね
それは一つ一つお釈迦様はすぐに説明していくんですね
窃盗することは全くよくないんだと
で 世界人類窃盗してはいけないではなくて
あなたは窃盗するなかれと
盗むなかれと よく知らない行為するなと
例えば人助けしながらよく知らない行為できるでしょうに
結婚している人がもうなかなか相手が見つからない女性のところに行って
あなたも寂しいんだからね
たまたま来てあなたも助けてあげますよという感じでも
欲しくもない行為はできるんです
その人もこの人 やっぱり私は寂しがっているんだからね
まあよくたまたま来ていただくんだと
それで幸せだと感じる感あるでしょう
そういうケースいくらでも世の中でありますから
そこで結果としてどうなるかというと
あの女性の方もどんどん勘違いするんですね
この人は私のためにすごく親切ですよと
だからその人の子供を産まなくちゃいけないんだと
その人と一緒にならなくてはならないんだと
そこでもうとっくに結婚しているんだから
そこで大変な不幸が生まれてくるでしょうね
結果としては 自分 今まで一緒にいた家族も不幸にするし
その人も不幸にするし
この間そうやってある女の人が 3回子供堕ろしたっていう話をテレビで聞いたんだけど
で だからこの その男性の人はやっぱり家族を持っていて
まあだからなんであんたそんなことやるの？やっぱりすごく優しいんだと
それで相手の人は優しいわけないでしょうと
と言っても やっぱり優しいんだと思っちゃう
すごい誤解されているんですね
ですから 単なる親切に社会福祉的に心を広げて生活したっても危ないと
もうそれだけでは幸福はのレベル足りませんと
だから道徳的な生き方で次にステップアップするんですね
そこで欲しくもない行為もしないで
嘘もつかないで 例えば人のために嘘をつく場合あるでしょ
世の中で 両親はよく子供たちに小さい時
結構嘘をつくでしょうに
で 我々も社会の中でこれ言っちゃったらまずいんだと
その人は困るんだと言って違うことを言う
でもそれではかえって後で不幸に
この政治的な世界では一応見えるんです
その現象は なんとか悪いことをして
それバレるようになってくると
あの まあそれまず否定する
で なぜ否定するかというと
本人自分のことだけ考えて否定するわけじゃないんです
例えば 国の権力を握っている一番偉い人だったら
はい 分かります 私はそういうことをやりましたと
で いきなり逃げてしまっちゃったら
自分の党の面倒どうしますかと
で その人々にも会わせる顔なくなっちゃいますからね
例えば ある党の首脳が何か悪いことをして言われたところで
はい そうですと 言って
すぐもう降りたと というと
党の他のメンバーたちにも問題が返ってくるんですね
あんた方はそれぐらいのけしからん人を選んだんですかと
信頼できないんだと ですから
そういう人々は 自分の政府のことやら党のことやら
いろんなことを考えて
国の安定よりやっぱり嘘ついちゃうんですね
でも結局それによって不幸になってしまう
相手方 あの 反対する方々は徹底的にそれを調べたり調べたりして
とにかく攻撃して その人の名誉をなくすようなことをする
ですから 最初からもうよく知らない行為やら悪いことやらしないで
心の道徳を守った方が幸せは安定するんだという話に行くんです
それよくできたら その話もものすごい幅広いんです
仏教の話の3分の1はその
その話ですからね 道徳の世界
分かりやすいんですね
道徳の世界っていうのは
それで仏教の道徳っていうのは
まああの 他の宗教でも同じでしょうと思いますけど
このあるいくつかの項目だけに項目だけに限っているわけじゃないんですね
皆さん 五戒文を唱えたでしょうに
じゃあ五戒だけ守れば仏教だと
そういうふうにリミットはできません
一応 この人間にはつかめつかめやすい法律的な文言あった方がやりやすいんです
ですから ５つにまとめて
普通の世界でその５つぐらいでも守りましょうと
でもそれぐらいではないんです
かなりの量あります それから４つのカテゴリに分けてまであるんです
それは出家の戒律の場合なんですけど
特にこの道徳だけではなくて
この社会的な行儀 それもそちらに入るんですね
この社会の決まり 守っているかいないか
習慣守っているかいないか
ちゃんと挨拶するか 感謝するか
お手洗い使ったらちゃんとあとの人のことを考えているかないか
一般的な公な場所を使うと
それは公の場所ですよと
みんなのところですよと
自分がちゃんと気にしているかいないか
そうやって社会的に我々は守らなくちゃいけないモラル
すごい厳密に書いてるんですね
一つ例で申し上げますけど
これ出家の場合なんですけど
出家っていうのは集団生活をしているんですね
で 私たちはだいたいお手洗ってトイレに行ったら
水を使って体を洗うんです
で そこで自分が今みたいに
この今はビデとかいろいろ簡単にありますけどね
昔は普通の水をくんで
それで体を洗うと で それやる時でも
あっちこっち水をこぼすなと
こぼしたらダメなんです
もしこぼしてしまったら
水をまた丁寧に全部洗っちゃうんです
洗ってきれいにして帰らなくちゃいけない
そこで自分 もし水を 水の入れ物が大きくて
半分の水で十分だとと思って
自分が半分使って 残り半分はそのまま置いていくと
それは戒律で禁止されているんです
そこまで厳密なんです
なぜかというと 次の人が来たら水半分あるんだからって
それを使う気持ちにはならないんです
ですから 自分使う水をそれ分だけ取って
それ残ったらそれ全部捨てて
下に向いてあれを入れておかなくちゃいけないんです
入れ物が残っている水も流れて出ていくようにと
で 次の人にはそうすると気持ちよくトイレ使えるんです
そういうこれは例で言いましたけど
まあ言うとたくさんありますからね
私はあまりやってないんだけど
例えば衣を着る時でも
ちゃんとこの袖のこれはちゃんと揃ってないといけないんです
下は であっちこちぶら下がったり
上に上がったりしてはいけません
きれいに丸めて着なくちゃいけないんです
それからこの腰巻きありますね
それは必ずもへその上で
へそが隠せるように ベルトはへその上で締めなくちゃいけないんです
で そういう例で いかに仏教はこの社会のことと
これも他人に対してなんです
それは礼儀なんです で
上の衣はお寺にいる時とかね
まあ一人でいる時は着なくてもいいんですけど
暑いし それでもちゃんと上までこれ腰巻きちゃんと巻いてるんだから
まあそれほど野蛮的には見えないと
村に出る時は決まってる
衣もまあもう 1枚ありますけどね
それ 3つも持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
いわゆるあの 何といいますか
その場合は あの ちゃんと服装
全部決まっているものは全部体にまとっていかなくちゃいけないと
で そうやってきめ細かいところまで
ほんのわずかなところまで生き方
そういう生き方になってくると
かなりの幸せな人間にはなるんです
ただ 行儀がいいということだけで
我々は人のことを大変喜ぶでしょう
行儀がいい人とは別に付き合うのは嫌でもないんですね
結構楽なんですね そこで食べ方
あるわあるわってもうキリがなくあるんです
トイレの話出したのはどれぐらい細かいかということということですから
食べる場合はどれぐらい細かいかと思いますかね
70 以上あります 行儀
口にご飯入れてしゃべってはいけないと
噛めるぐらいの量より大きく入れてはいけないんですね
口は大きく開けてはいけませんと
ご飯は口のところに戻る
戻す前に口を開けてはいけませんと
鳥とかヒヨコとかね あの親鳥がもう飛んでくるなと思ってもう口を開けてるでしょうね
そういう感じ ダメなんですね
時々人間もよくやりますけど
まだ箸でつかんでるだけなんです
でも口を開けてるんですね
私たちの戒律というのは
口のところに行ったら口を開けて入れて
口を閉めて噛むんです
そこはこの次の一ステップで
より安定した人間になるために
食べるとき 音を出すとはいけませんし
まあいろいろあったりして
そこら辺になってくると
かなり人間が落ち着く
立派になる すごい立派な行儀のいい
大変な素晴らしい文化人になるんです
そういう人々がもうどこかで遊びに森に入ったっても
森を壊すことはないんです
ゴミだらけにして帰ると
弁当箱やらビニール袋や使い捨てたい放題捨ててとかはないでしょう
それぐらい厳密に行儀を守るんだったら
それだけでもいかにこの社会幸せになるかと
社会として見ても でもそれは個人個人でやらなくちゃいけない責任を取ってとか
それだけでも幸せは安定しないんです
それだけでも 福祉行為だけでも
こういう行儀 戒律の世界だけでも安定しません
なぜかというと まだ人間ダメなんですね
突然人間が感情を出して
どうにもならない時もあります
いくら行儀よく人を助けていたっても
突然何かあったりする
何か不幸に出会ったりする
すぐヒステリーになってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで我を忘れてしまうんですね
だから 心にそれでも自分の幸福を壊せる恐れがあるんだと
例えば 現代風な例で言うならばね
子供が遊んでボールで遊んでいて
いきなり道路に飛び出したと
それで後ろから来た車にはねられたりする
そうすると いくらできている親であろうとも
これは我慢できないでしょうに
いきなりヒステリーになるでしょう
しょうがないんです それは
それであの車の運転さんを捕まって殺す可能性もあります
それぐらい感情が湧いてきます
だから幸せが安定してない
そこまで行ってもと それでお釈迦様は心を落ち着く方法
感情を湧いてこない方法
心に混乱が起きない方法を教えてあげるんですね
それで究極的に幸せになるんです
ということは この心を落ち着めていると
このサマーディの世界なんですけど
このサマーディっていうのは
私は現代風に違う言葉で言ってるんです
で なんかサマーディと聞いたらなんか宗教臭いでしょうし
私は言うのはサマーディ
すなわち興味 興味なんです
あれ すごいエネルギーなんです
興味あるということは集中力あるということなんですね
集中力あるということは興味あるっていうことなんです
ですから 集中力イコール興味であるならば
サマーディイコール興味なんです
興味ないと本を読めませんでしょうし
興味ないと勉強もできないでしょうし
興味あると苦しみがないんです
なんとなくすごい刺激的でワクワクするんですね
興味が湧いてくると 病気で体が痛くていたっても飛んでいっちゃうんです
あの痛みとかね 病気でああ嫌だ
もう病気で体が痛い 足が痛い
突然興味が出てきたら
全部飛んでいっちゃうんです
そのサマーディとして
お釈迦様はこのとことん
この一つのものに究極的に興味を作る方法を教えてあげちゃうんです
そこは清らかなものに興味持ちましょうと
悪いものには興味はどうしてもありますけど
それでは不幸になりますから
清らかなことに興味を作りましょう
興味が作るとどうなるかというと
脳細胞というのはすごい喜悦感で溢れちゃうんですね
おそらく現代 現代のの医学で言ってるような感じで
このエンドルフィンとかね
いっぱい出てくる可能性あります
それは快感の快感ホルモンなんです
私たちは美味しいご飯を食べて
すごい美味しいと快感を感じるということはないんです
その何でもいいんですけど
食べて快感感じるということは
これは脳の仕業なんです
だから物によって本当に幸福感を感じませんと
それで次のレベル高いステップなんですね
音楽を聴いて 美味しいものを食べて
家族で遊んで それだけでは本当の快感は感じないんだと
家族と遊んで楽しい時もあるし
もう疲れてもう嫌だと思う時もあるし
ご飯を食べて美味しいと感じる時もあるし
同じものを食べてまあ嫌だ
食べたくないということもあるんだから
はっきりしないんですね
ある音楽を聴いて楽しかったと
また他の時もううるさいんだと思ったりもするし
ですから 物に依存することによって純粋な喜悦感は感じませんと
それは脳の仕業だから
脳の方で育ててみればどうですかと言って
サマーディの世界に紹介するんです
そこ終わったらその人に哲学を喋り始めるんです
真理ってどういうものかと
なぜそうなるんですかと
生命はどういう風に どういう風にあるんだ
地獄の話やら人間の話やら
畜生の話やら 天の話やら
いろいろ話をつけちゃうんです
これ時間論とかね 動物で生まれたら
まあそれなりに 10年とか 20年とか
あるいは 1週間でとか死んでしまっちゃいます
人間に生まれたら その生命次元によって
100年ぐらいは生きていられるんだよと
もし違う次元で生まれたら
これはもう 1万人  100万年とか
それぞれ寿命は延び延びますよ
寿命は長い 寿命は長ければ長いほど苦しみは少ないんだと
という時間次元論も喋って
それからものの構成とかね
喋って すごく心がものすごく抜群に成長したところで
すべては無常ですよと
いくらなんでも捨てた方がいいと最終的に解脱のことを言うんです
それはお釈迦様が後で使った説法の手段なんです
その方で結構みんなわかったんですね
そういうことで大変大きな構成になってます
そこで一部だけ取って膨張しちゃうと変になるんです
なぜ仏教は宗派に分かれたんですかというと
そういうこと 何か一つだけ言葉を取って
自分で膨張したい放題膨張させる
それでは健康的に育てるわけじゃないんです
一部だけ 例えばすべてはこうですよとそれだけ言いふらしちゃうと
どうせ悲観論になってしまっちゃうし
あるいはもう戒律だけ気に入ってしまって
戒律は厳密に守らなくちゃいっちゃったら
なんかガリガリ行者になるだけで
柔軟性ある大きな人間にならなくなっちゃうんですね
そこでそうやってガリガリ修行好きな人はそこに行くんだけど
おおらかで大雑把に生きていた人には気に入らないんですね
日本でも律宗とか何とかという宗派がありましたね
今もありますけど それはものすごい厳密に戒律
ただそれだけでと そうやって宗派作っちゃうと
あの仏教の大きさがなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから お釈迦様はものすごく注意したんですね
例えば自由な教えだといっても
学派は作るなと 分けてはいけませんと
離れてはいけませんと
それは私は一つの目的があって
お互いにそれ その場で
その場で そのその人に理解できるように喋っているだけだから
言葉を取って喧嘩してはいけないんだと
それはどんな時言ったんですかというと
ある時はある人が在家の人なんですけど
このお坊さん あるお坊さんに聞くんで
お釈迦様は十感覚がどれぐらいあります？説明してるんですか？と聞いたら
その人は三つですよと言うんですね
そしたら在家の人に違いますよと
2つですよと でお坊さんがいえ
三つですよと お互いに認めないんですね
そこじゃあお釈迦様に聞いてみましょうと聞いたら
ところでお釈迦様はものすごく叱るんですね
いい加減にしなさいと
私は時において一つだという場合もありますと
2つだという場合もありますと
3つだという場合もありますと
感覚は十八があるという場合もありますと
百八 百八ある場合ありますよという場合もありますよと
それはその場で その場で
その話の内容によりますよと
あんた方はそれは適当に理解したらどうですかと
それこそ正しい 他の教えは間違っていると喧嘩してはいけませんということで叱られただけなんです
結果は そういうことで
この全体的に 仏教を見た方がものすごい完全なセットなんです
そこで悟りの世界とはもうものすごく脱却してしまったんだけど
そういうわけで なぜ悟るかという質問
我々の頭の中で生まれるならば
私はすごい失礼な逆な質問を聞きたいんです
なぜ人間が幸せになって悪いんですかと
なぜ幸福になって悪いんですかと
何か悪いことでもありますかと
なぜ人間が苦しまなくちゃいけないんですかと
ただそれだけの答えなんです
ですから この仏教はこの
別に悲観的なペシミズムでもないし
だからといってオプティミズムでもないんですね
このペシミズムもオプティミズムも偏見なんです
世の中をペシミスティックに見る
悲観的に見る それおかしいんです
世の中悪いだけじゃないんだから
うまくいけばいい時もうまくいく場合もあります
それでオプティミズムで見る
楽観主義で見ると 楽観主義で見たら
それはちょっと甘いんですね
話は 甘すぎ 人間はかなり苦労して
やっと幸福というものを掴まえますから
そんな楽観主義で見て困るんです
いくら幸せに恵まれていたとしたっても
洪水が来るわ 地震が起こるわと
あるんじゃないんですか
ですから 楽観主義でも仏教ではないんです
でも 仏教は幸福の道を教えるのであって
幸福になる方法を教えるのであって
それは楽な方法ですかと
苦しい方法ですかということはまた別な話なんで
人によって楽かもしれませんし
人によって苦しいかもしれませんし
それは個人の差であって
例えば嘘を言わないと決めたならば
ある人にとっては何のこともないんだと
ある人にとっては これすごい地獄に落ちたように苦しみだと
それは個人の差なんですね
だから幸福の道 苦しみを乗り越える道
その方法は楽しいか楽かということは各自の問題であるということで
どんな主義にも入らないんです
仏教は どんな主義にも入らない
だから中道と言うんですね
それも一つ理由なんですね
中道というのは 中道というのは中途半端ということではなくて
しっかりして 物事を考えて
選択して 選択して 前向いて行く道
ですから超越道なんですね
どちらにも捕まれないで
よし で あの まあそこら辺で今まで喋ったポイントを終了します
で まあ一応本格的に悟りのテーマに行かないと
まあ悟りっていうのは
まあいろんな言葉で表現できますけど
悟りそのものの説明はできないとはっきりと言っておいたんです
最初も だからこれは推測するんですね
で ですから 今からもこの推測の世界なんですね
で 悟りについて この捨てる道だと言ってるんです
つかむ道ではなくて 捨てる道だと
で そう言われた途端 出世間的なんですね
人間というのはつかむ道にいるんですね
ものを収集しようと そうでないと落ち着かないんです
いっぱいものあると ああ
楽しいだと思っちゃうんですね
お金がいっぱいあると
友達がいっぱいいると
楽しいっていうふうに
そこで問題は  それも仏教は否定しませんよ
家族いないよりはいた方がよろしいし
友達がいないよりはいた方がいいし
お金がないよりはあった方がいいし
ご飯はないよりはあった方がいい
では当たり前のことなんでしょうに
着る服にしたっても ボロボロ服よりは綺麗な服の方がいいし
それは楽しいんです 確かに
どこかでビニールシートを張って寝るよりは
ボロでアパートでもいいし
アパートの方がよろしいし
アパートよりはマンションの方がいいかもしれませんし
マンションよりは一軒家はいいかもしれませんし
それよりも豪邸の方がいいかもしれません
それはもう当たり前のことなんです
大きな庭付きで スイミングプールも付きで家があったら何が悪いんですかね
決して悪くないんです
それは否定してるわけじゃないんです
でもなんで解脱は捨てる道だというんですかね
そこで客観的に世の中を見ると
この収集する方向 捕まる方向でちょっとしたトラブルがあるんですね
一つは ものを掴まるためには
それぐらい苦しみで払わなくちゃいけないんです
そこで人間がプラスマイナス考えて
プラスの方が多いければ
その苦しみを受けるんですね
例えば 年勉強したところで
まあ歳まで あるいは歳まで仕事をできるんだと思ったら
年はもう並ならぬ苦労したってもどうったことないんですね
プラスマイナス考えちゃうと
マイナスの方よりはプラスの方が多いんですね
でもマイナスの方 多ければやめた方がいいんでしょうし
とにかく幸福になるものをつかまって幸福になるということを思うならば
その分かなり苦労しなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば 人が作家になろうとする
はい 明日から私は作家ですよと
そんなことはならないんですね
その人はかなり苦労して
いろんなことを勉強して
把握して 理解して かみしめて
それまたいろいろ工夫しながら
かなり苦労して書かなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから この収集過程は苦しみを伴っているんです
苦労を伴っているんです
それは決して否定できません
例えば お金いっぱいあった方が楽しいんですけど
外へ出て雨が降ってるんだから
この間 １万冊でも降ってくるでしょうと
何もしないで待っていたっても
1回も降ってくれません
そこは事実なんです 金脈でを発見したら
大変金持ちになりますよ
だからって楽じゃないんです
それも ほんのちょっとテレビでこのアフリカとか
あのダイヤ掘ったりするでしょうに
そこを見ても ものすごい恐ろしい自然破壊と
あの掘る人々の苦しみを見ると
みんななんとかダイヤもうもう 1 年間も何も見つからなかったとか言いながら
それでも食べない 食べるものもなくて
苦労して苦労して すごいもう想像を絶する重労働なんです
やっと 1つ 2つ見つかったところで
商売人に売ると もってお金もらってみんなで分けますけど
全然金持ちで何にもならない
ただ給料分ぐらいなんですね
結局みんな そういうことでかなり苦労しなくちゃいけない
穴掘っただけで大きなダイヤが見つかりましたって
そんなありえない話なんです
石油で豊かになっている国々もありますけど
一つの油田を掘るためにどれぐらいお金がかかるかと
だから この収集することで幸せつかまりますよと言ったら
覚悟を決めて その分も大変苦労もしなくちゃいけないんだということを理解してはならないんですね
だから否定しているわけじゃないんです
まあ別にプラスマイナス考えれば
プラスだったらやるやることは当たり前でしょうしね
そんなことはお釈迦様が言わなくても誰でもやっているし
だけど捨てる道ですよというと
この収集するとどんどん幸福になるかもしれませんだけど
どんどん自分の自分というものがすっごく重くなっているんです
自由を失っていっちゃうんですね
得た幸福よりは責任感と他の悩みはもう切りがないんですね
そこももう結果として出てくるんですね
だから お金何もない時は
自由にあっちこっちみんなと仲良く喋ったりした人が
どんどんどんどん金持ちになってくると
どんどんどんどん彼が社会から離れて離れて
隠れて隠れて 厳密に警備されている世界に閉じ込めなくてはならないんですね
だから結局 自分で普通の人と違って
自分で自分の刑務所を作って
そこに入って鍵をかけるんだと
それだったら 人をぶん殴って刑務所にいる人の方がマシなんですね
だから そこら辺も考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
そこで自分持っているものを捨てると
長持ちする楽 軽さが生まれるんです
例えば総理大臣になったとする
なかなかみんな協力してくれないで
いろいろもう批判ばっかりしたりして
うまくいかないんだと
でも 自分ではやりたい
やりたいと思う限りはすごい苦しいんですね
そこで頭のいい人だったら
あんた方そんなに反対するんだったら
勝手にやれば私は辞めますと
辞めた瞬間に その人はもしすごい楽を感じるならば
その楽は死ぬまで残るんです
でも 総理大臣になって得られる幸福は
その職に就いている時だけ
短いんです 時間が だから
この収集する幸福の道が命短い
命短いだけではなくて
そのプラスアルファでいっぱい心配事はついてくる
得るためにも苦しみを得なくちゃいけないし
得たところでプラスアルファで心配事いっぱい囲んでくる
それでも命短い 幸福の
それで捨てたことによって
ずっと続くんです あの楽ということ
綺麗な人と結婚すると楽しいんです
でも命短いんです その美しさも体の力もずっとあるわけじゃないんです
ずっと一緒にいると あの美しさ見えなくなっちゃうんですね
毎日見ているんだからね
で 一人で人に頼らないでいられますよと思ったら
その楽しみはずっと続くんですね
そういうことで この心の中にある
この取りたい取りたい
掴みたい掴みたいという
その気持ちを逆にして
離れたい離れたいという方向へ持っていけば
どんどんどんどんどんどんどんどん幸せになっていくんだと
楽に楽に楽になっていくんだと
その方向でジェラスを語っているんです
捨てれば捨てるほど楽ですよ
楽しいですよと そこで執着はどれぐらい人間は馬鹿にするかというと
今現在 このユーゴスラビアに戦争があるんですね
すごく人々が苦しんでいるんですね
スロヴェニア人もアルベニア人も
限りなく苦しんでいるんですね
あれ なんでしょうかね
あの苦しみが それは人間の馬鹿げたな執着なんですね
アルベニア人がイスラム教だから
自分たちの世界を作らなくちゃ
あいつらを追い出さなくちゃいけないかと
スロヴェニア人も この連中はもうもう 600年前から来て
我々に迷惑をかけていて
こういう人々は追い出さなくちゃいけないと
我々は別になくちゃいけない
何の意味ありますかね
そういうことで そこは 100年
200年続くと なかなか捨てられないんですね
いくら言ったっても アルベニア人に説得することはできますか？あなた方はね
みんなと仲良くしなさいと
こんな別れて別にボスニアとか何とか自分の国にするんじゃなくて
まあみんなでもう国境線なんかまあ捨ててしまえ
人間ではないかと それできますか？説得することはできないでしょ
すごい簡単なことでしょう
考えてみれば 何人やということを捨てちゃえばいいでしょうに
生まれる時ラベル貼ってくれるわけじゃないんだから
頭の上でも額でもどこかに
あなたはこんなこの人だと
ああいう余計なプライドとかね
何を守ってるんですか？あの人々は
守っているつもりで失っていくでしょ
アルベニア人が何かアルベニア民族を守ろうと思って
結果はみんな難民なんです
そこでそっちに退避しているあの人も
自分の国民を守っているんですかね
結局殺されているだけで
爆弾を落とされているだけだから
そこでNATO軍にもものすごいもってこい場所なんです
向こうは反対しませんだから
綺麗に明確に的を絞って絞って爆弾を落とされるんです
やりたい放題 爆弾落としたい放題なんです
そこでだから命中するように
大統領の家は命中するようにとかね
それで列車には命中するようにとかね
爆弾落としたりする 本当に命中して
それで威張っちゃうでしょ
おそらく それは向こうは反対しないんだからね
自分を撃ち落とせるという恐れもないし
それはそれで とにかく仏教の立場から言うと
何の意味もない 何の役にも立たないこの執着から
並みならぬ苦しみ 受けてるでしょうに
だから捨てちゃえばそれだけでもう幸せでしょうに
イスラム教だからってなんで戦争するんですかね
で 皆様は初期仏教をここで勉強している
他のところに行ったら他のことを人々は勉強する
それで別になんで喧嘩するんですかね
それは後から生まれてから
まあ好き勝手にやっていることだから
本来のものじゃないでしょうに
でも人間というのはあまりにも馬鹿げたことで
生まれる時は何も持ってないで
何人でもなく どんな言葉もなく生まれるのに
生まれた方は拾ったゴミによって人類までも破壊するんですね
だから私はすべてのものはゴミだと言うんです
文化も全部 生まれたから拾ったもんでしょうに
そんなものは とにかくゴミを拾う
ある人が生まれて初めて日本語を勉強したら
我が日本国語とかなんとか執着する
白人たちが私たちの英語やらドイツ語やらと
そこでまた執着をする
そこで喧嘩になる 英語にしたっても
イギリスの英語とアメリカ英語はまた違うでしょうに
それぞれの国では厳密なんです
私たちは留学生で 外人でいて
例えば論文を書こうとしたら
もうアメリカだったらアメリカで厳しくチェックするんです
アメリカ英語かないかと
イギリスに行ったら そこでイギリスの英語かないかと厳しくチェックするんです AT
のAT使うか ONのオン使うかと
エレベーターというかリフトというかと
そんなもんなんです だから私が言うのはもうすべて拾ったゴミでしょうに
結局は まあゴミでも役に立つんだから拾ってるかもしれませんだけど
それでもってなんで人殺しをするんですかって
並みならぬ苦しみでしょうに
皆様方は我々は日本人だと思ったところで
他の人々からもう自分たちが隔離されるでしょうに
精神的には そうすると日本人であることを守らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから中国ともなかなかうまくいかないし
韓国ともなかなかうまくいかないとか
いろいろ日本ではそれほど大きな問題はないかもしれませんだけど
世界を見ると そういうわけで
論理的に言えば捨てた方が幸せだよと
苦しみ何もないんだと
言って この心にある病気治す
捕まらなきゃ取らなきゃ我慢できないと
不満だと お金がなかったら不満だと
というこの心の弱みを直すことを悟りの世界なんです
あってもなくても別にもう安心しましょうと
ということで 次のポイントにはもうちょっと5分ぐらい休みを取って
皆様疲れているでしょうと思いますけど
で よろしいでしょうか
で 話続きますけど まあ捨てられない我々の心を
育てる方法は解脱というんですね
捨てられるようにする
あの捕まれ捕ままらなきゃ不安だと
取らなくては不安だと思う
我々の心を直しちゃうんですね
ですから そこはそれほど簡単じゃないんですね
それは批判的な言葉で言うならば
人間の生きがいをなくさせていることなんです
どういうことかというと
例えばあの昔はね 国のためにと言ってみんな死んでしまったでしょうに
でも何かに何か頭の中に変な概念があったら
もう幸福だと思って死ぬんです
普通に考えれば 自分の命を捨てることはどこが幸福かとわかりませんだけどね
だからこの でもその時は頭に叩き込んであげる
マインドコントロールする
国のためなら 国の役に立つんだったら
まあ自分の命は別にどうったことない
それで役に立ちますか？というまた問題もあるし
それ逆に なんで国のために誰かさんが死ななくちゃいけないんですかね
で アメリカの若い人々でも関係ない国に行ったり
戦争したりとかね あれは生きがいなんです
関係ないところに行って人殺して帰ると
どうだ アメリカの力という風に
そうやって私たちには何か目的
それはたとえ馬鹿げたことであろうか
その何か目的に操られて生きているんですね
それは生きがいなんですね
そこで論理的に考えると
それはものすごく馬鹿げたの馬鹿げた話なんです
で 国のためとかね 自分の民族のためだと
民族を解放しなくちゃいけない
自分の国でも同じ問題あります
インドから入ってきた方の
もう１５パーセントもいませんだけどね
国を欲しいんだと あれは我々仏教でいうのは
国もみんなのものだからあげられませんと
みんなのものだと だから彼らにも１００パーセント自由がありますから
権利ありますから それ故何が欲しいんですかと
民族差別で仕事も選べませんし
大学も決めることはないし
どこでも住めるし 仕事もできるし
それでは足りませんと
自分たちで支配しなくちゃいけないということで
テロたちがじゃあ解放軍を作りましょうと言って
死んでいるのは誰ですかというと
そちらが死んでいるんです
でもだから８歳 １０歳の子供たちを捕まって
自爆団やらいろいろね
まあそこだけ教えてあげて
首にサイナイですか サイナイって日本語で何て言います
サイナイはな何さん 食べたらすぐ死んじゃう
え？青酸カリ 入れてる何か
薬みたいなものをね 首にいつでもぶら下がっているんです
で 捕まったらもうすぐそれ飲んじゃうんです
みんな子供たちなんです
それはもう政府にとっては見ていられなくて
国連に訴えて訴えて これを何とかしなさいと
大人が出て戦争に出てくるんだったら
こちらの大人の軍隊に見て戦えますけどね
子供たちに向かって鉄砲を撃てませんし
まあそこをもう今いろいろまあ国連の力も借りていろいろやってますけどね
だからユーゴスラビアは違って
自分の国だったら この多種民族はいつでも平和でいたいと
仲良くしましょうと 国を境界線引いて分けちゃったら
あなた方も苦しいんだと
というふうに話はそこで嫌です
嫌ですという話だけで
なぜ嫌かと言わない だから病気なんですね
結局は そこでまあ解放軍というなんとか作って
結局殺してるだけなんですね
自分の民族 だからいっぱい殺されたのは同じ自分の民族なんです
それは国際ニュース関係でもう逆に報道するだけで
これぐらい殺された これぐらい殺されたと
だからこの見ていられないんですね
この人間の生きがいというものは
昔はね まあ例えば労働者の解放だと思って
どういうことを人殺したんですかと
解放するしたんですかね
ソ連にしたっても いろいろ共産圏の国々にしたっても
結局労働者がもう囚われ身であって
ずっとその調子でしょうに
そうやって人間にはこの何か掴まるということで生きがいを見つかって
もう生きているんだけど
私たち仏教で聞くのは
あんた方は本当に生きているんですかと
それで幸せつかまってるんですかと
やっていることはもう違うんじゃないんですかと
例えば ある宗教を信仰するということになる
自分の宗教のためにといって
並ならぬ苦しみを味わっちゃうんです
何かの幸せをつかまり
つかまりたくて宗教を信仰したならば
幸せをつかまってほしいんです
なんで自分の宗教は正しいと思ったら
他の宗教は間違ってるんじゃ殺しましょうと
昔はキリスト教の世界そうでしたでしょうし
とにかく人殺し 人殺しだけで
今はもうイスラム教は元気で頑張ってますけど
アフガニスタンにしたっても
もう全く自由がない 原理主義者に囚われたタリバンとかなんとか言いますけどね
あれで幸せですかと 子供たちを戦争に出して殺されちゃったりして
ですから この生きがい
何かないかなければ生きていられませんというのは
もう考え直した方がいいんです
何か引っ掛けなかったら動かないという
このもう人間のこの弱みをなく直した方がいいんです
そこで仏教でいうのは智慧ですよと
智慧があるとすごい活発的にはなります
行動はしますけど 目的はない
変な目的というか 変な生きがいはない
というわけで このヴィパッサナー瞑想なんかは正しくなさるんだったら
自分のやり方がいい方向へ行くならば
すごい元気になるんです
ものすごいアクティブになるんです
物事を見えてきて 理解できてくるんだから
見えて見えてくるということは
ある人がなんか目で見えるとすごい誤解していたんだけどね
目で見えるんじゃないんですけどね
物事をわかってしまうと
なんか自分がちょっと優先的な立場にいるんじゃないかなとわかるんですね
それですごく自由に行動できるんです
何か生きがいなんか作ったということは
自分の視野視野がすごく狭くしたということなんです
それで自分やっていることは
自分にとってプラスかマイナスか
社会にとってプラスかマイナスか
まるっきりわかってないんです
ですから ずっと人類の歴史を見ても呆れちゃうんですね
結局何もやったことはないことになっちゃうんですね
偉大なる建物を作ったりとかね
我々は史跡だと言って見たりはするんだけどね
その人々 ピラミッドなんか作るためにはどれぐらい人を殺しましたかとか
だからで何かになったんですかというと
別にあれはもう泥棒に盗まれるだけの
ニュースで見たんだけど
レニンの何とか大きな銅像が彼の誕生日で爆破したんだとするか
どっちかだか分かりませんだけど
そうやって今もね まあ北朝鮮だったらやっぱりまた崇拝してもらおうと
本当に国民が幸せになってるんですか？その崇拝することで
ただ単にマインドコントロールされているだけじゃないかなと
だからこの生きがいを探す理由はこういう理由なんです
実は私は頑張りたくない
行動したくない でもこういう目的あったら頑張るんだと
そういう理屈でしょ 生きがいなかったら生きていられないということは
ということは もともと生きていられないんです
怠け者なんです そこはなんで直さないんですかね
その代わりに じゃあこれから何とかの目的を目指して頑張りましょうと
もともとはそのままでしょうね
それの何とか目的がなければ頑張らないんだから
富士山制覇しましょうとか
じゃあ頑張りましょうと
そこでお釈迦様から見れば
あんた方はこのもともとの問題解決してないんだと
この本来元来持っているこの怠け
そこなければ人間行動するでしょうに
お釈迦様はすべての目的を捨てて
すべての煩悩を捨ててしまったんだけど
１ 日 １ 時間しか 1時間半しか寝てないんです
毎日毎日もう何百キロでも歩くんです
歩いて人に説法する 人が仏教わかるだなと理解できるだなと思ったら
一人のためにでも歩くんです
だからほんのちょっとでも行動は止めたことはないんです
ものすごいみんなびっくりするほど行動的
亡くなった時も 3ヶ月間もっと半年間ぐらいかけて
ものずっと歩いていたんですね
もう 80歳で体がボロボロで疲れるわ疲れるわ
それでもまた立ち上がってまた歩くと
それで仏教は教えなくて
それは私は全然あなた方に対して別に希望も何もないんだとも言うんです
比丘たちは私の弟子になってありがたいとか思ったこともないんだと
私に依存するなと はっきり言おう
私に依存するな 構うなと
あんた方の人生でしょう
自分たちで頑張りなさいと
自分のことを放っておきなさいと
そう言いながら でもだからで黙ってたんですけど
そうでもないんです ものすごい元気でエネルギッシュで頑張るんです
それで最後にものすごい体が苦しくて
病気で倒れながら それでも歩いて歩いていて
途中でもう歩けないとなくなったところで亡くなったんですね
だから最後の息を引く瞬間まで
ものすごくエネルギッシュで行動していたんです
最初にもう寝て まあ終わりですよと
これからはもう立ちませんということになって
その時も一人の人が走ってきたんですね
私はやっぱり このブッダに会って話したいんだと
真理を知りたいんだと
そしたら他の人々はもう
もう今はその年ではないんだと
お釈迦様はそろそろもう亡くなるんだと
言ったら何の騒ぎですかと
これ喋れないんですよ
もう死にかけている瞬間だから
え？まあ こんな時間でこんな人が来てまだ質問しますよと言うんだから
一生 もう歳から歳までみんなの質問に答えていたのに
死ぬ瞬間でも放っておけないんだと
この連中はということをお釈迦様に報告した
お釈迦様 通りなさいと
その人は そこで横になって寝ていたままで
最後にその人にそれでも真理を語って教えてあげたんです
ですから この生きがいというのは結局危険なもので
我々心の中で怠けさえなければ
目的なければ動かないというね
その弱みさえ取ってしまえば
自由に行動できるんです
目的やったら それはたとえ他人に迷惑であろうとも
それ実行するでしょ ですから
目的ない人の行動っていうのは
役に立つか立たないか
ただそれだけの判断で
だから何の危険もないんです
あ これは役に立たない
やめますと これは役に立ちますから
やりますと 人のためになるかならないか
ただそれだけの選択で
行動しているんですね
そういうわけで この悟りという
この悟りそのものの説明はできませんが
悟りの道というのはものすごい心を強くする道なんです
それからこの知識と知恵はもう限りなく発展させる
知識はもう世俗的で もうもう大変複雑だから
そこら辺は適当でいいんですね
勉強は でも知恵は適当ではダメなんです
知恵っていうのは人間本来持つべきものだから
それは完璧でなきゃいけないんですね
まあ知恵っていうのは能力のようなもので
知識っていうのは まあ自分がどれぐらいものを掴まってるかと
ということなんですね
だから能力あるとものを掴まれるでしょ
で 我々いうのは能力は抜群にあればいいんです
でも捕まるものは適当に
ほどほどに 自分で管理できるぐらい
にしましょうと ですから
知識はまあほどほどでいいんです
知恵にはほどほどはないんです
そうやってこの知恵を開発する方法なんですね
知恵を完成したところに我々は悟りというんです
そういうわけで この仏道の道っていうのは
これみんな実践していないだけのわけですけど
とにかくけなされているわけで
批判されているだけで誤解するだけのひどい運命なんですけど
仏教の運命っていうのは
でも真理語ってるんだからね
そんな簡単には死ぬということでもないんですね
すごい力強いんです なぜ力強いかというと
力を持っていないんだからなんです
倒せません ヨーロッパの方から我々の国にもう戦略してきて
どれほど人を殺したかというと
この自分の宗教を広げるために
何の武器も鉄砲も持ってない人々
野蛮人が野蛮人だと でも黙って抵抗していないなかった人々が
逆にヨーロッパ人にも教えてあげたんです
それで彼らが大学の研究所やらいろいろ作って
もう財産持ってるし ノウハウも持ってるし
そこで世界中どこでも広げるようにするんですね
本人知らないんです 自分たちがこれ仏教を宣伝しているんだと
だから僕らも使ってる本やらテキストやら
全部作ってもらったんです
違う宗教の方々作ったものなんです
笑っちゃうんですよ 真理の世界にいると何のこともないんで安全なんです
そうやってで このなかなかあのメッセージが届いてない
人間の心に正しく だから知らない
だからもう一つのへんてこりんな迷信的な教えだろうと
まあ普通判断して勘違いする
まあそれで仏教に対していろいろ非難やら出てきたりするだけのことで
正しく見れば これは宗教でも何でもない
単なる人間論であって
誰が実行したっても必ずしも幸せになるだけであって
ですから 知恵はなぜ悪いかと
私たちは逆に聞きたいんだけど
頭が良くなることはなぜ悪いんですか？と
自分で判断能力を持てることはなぜ悪いんですか？と
誰にも頼らない独立するのは精神的になぜ悪いんですか？と
マインドコントロールされないような心を作るのはなぜ悪いんですか？と
他人に操られ操れない人間になるのはなぜ悪いんですか？と
地震が起きても 財産が雨のように降ってきたっても
平安な心でいるのはなぜ悪いんですか？と
たとえ自分の親戚やら子どもたちやら
何か不幸なことに出会って
みんな１日で死んだりする
それでも 世の中のことはそのもの
そのようなものですよと
個人にはどうしてもコントロールできるものじゃないんだと
宇宙の法則っていうのは
そうやって知恵を持って平安でいるのは何で悪いんですか？ちょっと子供を怪我して子供が怪我しただけでヒステリーになって
もう世界中みんな壊そうとしているような姿勢になること正しいんですかね
お母さんで普通でしょうね
子供が喧嘩しちゃったら
隣の家にいて その子供にぶん殴ろうとしているんだから
それは正しいんですか？あるいはまあそんなもんやと
ガキだから喧嘩するだろうと
平安でいることは何で悪いんですかね
そういうことでもう これは幸福の道なんです
究極な幸福は解脱なんです
ですから ニッバーナパラマンスカン
この前書いたでしょうと思いますけど
ニッバーナパラマンスカン
ニッバーナ 涅槃 はパラマン
最高な究極な主観幸せである
と そういうわけで 決して嫌なもんじゃないんです
それでもう一つポイントがあります
もう一つ この他のどんな宗教でもね
究極的な幸せということを語ってますけど
私たちはこれは今ここで体験できるんだと
すごいこのインテリ的な教えだから
科学的な教えだから すぐ結果が出ないとちょっと怪しいんだと
だからチャレンジするんです
すごく力強くやってみなさいと
何が悪いかとやってみてください
もし何かあったら 文句あったら言ってみなさいと
ただそれだけ そういうふうにもチャレンジまでするんです
脅しはない 地獄に行きますよと
脅しは全くない そういうのはレベル低い
やってみたらと 別にもう信仰はないんだから
信仰の場合は 一つの宗教を信仰するために
他の宗教を捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
どちらが正しいかとハッキリしていない場合は
捨てていいかあるいはどうかわからないでしょうに
例えば ジェホワという神様を信仰している人が
そこを入れ替えてアッラーという神様を信仰するようになると
どちらが正しいかわかりますかね
戸籍はないんだから 神様に調べるわけにいけません
正しい名前はどっちですかと
ですから まあそういうことではないんだから
これ信仰しなさいと 事実だから信仰しない方がいいんです
試せばわかるんだから
カラスは黒いですよってなぜ信じなくちゃいけないんですか？カラスは黒いんだから
それは事実であるし でも希望叶ってくる青い鳥がいますよということは信じなくちゃいけないんですね
なぜならば それはそんなことはないんだから
いくら死んでもまた生き返ってくる
ヒノドリですか？フィーニスですか
それは信じなくてはならないんです
見たこともないんだから
でもカラスは黒いだと信じるバカがいないと思いますけどね
そこはこの言葉のちょっとした問題ですけどね
まあ我々は知っているという事実ということにも信じるという言葉を言いますけど
でもあまりにも事実だったら信じるという言葉を使いませんね
あんまりにも明確な事実には使いません
まあまあ そこそこ真実の場合は
まあ私はやっぱり信じていますよと言うんです
ですから 仏教でいうのは
このあんまりにも明確な事実なんです
ですから 信じるという言葉は入れておいて
で 実行できるんです 我々言うのは
納得という言葉の信仰の代わりに
もしこの論理に納得したならば
納得ぐらいなければやってみることもできませんだからね
だから この実践していただくためには
いくらか話を聞いて この納得してもらう
納得することには 信という言葉を使っているんです
それは信仰ではないんです
納得いくためには事実必要なんです
証拠必要なんです ですから
証拠に基づいている理解に
仏教ではこの信という言葉を使ってますけどね
それと普通の世俗的な世界で言ってる知らないものは信じるんだという
信じる者は救われるんだと
ひどい目にあいますから
信じる者はもう信じてしまったら
言ってること自体もことわざみたいに言うんだけど
ものすごい危ないんです
だから今日はあまり時間がないんだけど
世の中で言ってることわざやらいろいろ一つ一つ見ると
もう危なくてしょうがない
危険ばっかしで不幸を作るばっかしで
それでもやるんですね
地球の人類が何の意味もない
いろんな概念やら物事に執着して
並ならぬ苦しみを味わっているのに
それでもやるんですね
原子爆弾を作ったら大変だと知っているのにも
お金もないのにも関わらず
パキスタンもインドもみんな爆弾作ったりする
え 何のためかと 国民のことをそんなに大事に真剣に考えるんだったら
国の貧しさ 貧困をなくすために頑張ればいいでしょうに
それだったら世界とみんなと仲良くした方が一番やりやすいでしょうに
インドとやり合っちゃうんじゃなくて
パキスタンにしたっても
仲良くしましょう どっちにしたっても同じ人間だからといって
簡単なことでしょうに
私たちのこんなところで言う場合はね
パキスタン人にしたっても同じインド人なんです
昔は国は一つでしたから
そこで外からもう何か宗教入っただけのことで
国は 3つに分けなくちゃいけないんですね
考えてバカバカしいでしょうに
アッラ信仰しようがバラモン信仰しようが
もうどっちでも知らないもんだからね
遊びでいいんでしょうに
それによってなんで国ごとに戦争するんですかね
それで原子爆弾まで作ると
それ幸せになるはずがないでしょ
それでもやるこの人間の無知
それからそれは幸せの道だと
仏教なんかクソ食らえというこの愚かさというのは
まあそういうふうな物事を考えると
私たちには個人個人にでも楽しく幸せに生きていられる心がどんどん出てくるだろうと思います
で それで悟りというのは
この宇宙的な普遍的な真理なんです
ある個人が修行するかもしれませんだけど
その個人がこの普遍的な真理を発見するんです
だから どんな個人が修行して悟ったっても
悟ったらもう同じなんです
ある一部学問勉強することじゃないんです
いくら勉強を進んでやっても
学問の世界では専門的な研究だから一部しか知らないんです
その問題は智慧の世界ではないんです
個人は個人で 知識は別々バラバラなんですけど
智慧の世界では宇宙的な存命の基本的な真理を発見するということだから
一旦発見したら誰でも同じ真理を発見しているんです
誰の心の境地も同じなんです
そういうことで この悟りという本格的な悟りの方に行くと
普通というより ものすごいものすごい幅広いレベルで物事を見たり考えてりしなきゃいけません
自分が単なる生命一個という立場で
他のものも生命の一個一個一個ですよと
そういう立場で物事を見なくちゃいけない
で そこのその立場から
私はなぜ悟れないかと
その問題を扱ってみたいんですね
今日は時間ないんだからそこら辺で終了いたしますけど
なぜ悟れないかと で そういう質問には
皆様 仏教経典なんか読むと
いろいろ答えが出てくるかもしれません
輪廻で修行したことがないんだとか
徳を積んだことがなかったんですかとかね
でも私はある自由な人間として
そういう説明には納得いかないんです
もし長い輪廻の中で修行を積んだことがないんですよ
だから悟れませんよ そんな証拠はないんです
あなたに仏縁がないんですよと
どうやって言えるんですかね
なければ作っちゃえばよろしいし
そこで科学的にどんな人間にも納得いける理由が言ってくれないと
それはお釈迦様からの経典から言うと
この人間の主観的な見方
物事を主観的にしか人間には見られないんです
だからものは見えませんと
理由はただそれだけ 私から言えば
いわゆる誰にでも納得いける理由は
ここに私が見ているというでしょう
それ私が見ているんだから
私に見える視覚なんです
私が考えているんだから
それは私の思考なんです
こうやって私たちの生っていうのは構成されているんです
主観的になるようにと
それでほんのちょっとの理屈で
それ破れるんです で まず世俗的な考え方で私が見たんだからと
それを証拠にするんですね
例えば ある特定の店があって
その店のラーメンは美味しいですよと
なぜですかと 私は食べたんだから
それ我々納得いくでしょ
あんた食べたんで美味しかった
まあそうだったら美味しいとすぐ決めるんです
誰かさんがものすごい綺麗
美しいですよと なぜですかと
私が見たんだから 本人を
そうやって世の中で事実というものは広げようとするんだけど
ほとんどは見ていないのに見たように喋る
ニュースなんかそんなもんでしょうね
事実無根で堂々と創作して創作してニュース作る
そこら辺まで行ってないんだけど
一応世の中に広げてる事実というものは
私が見たんだから 私は聞いたんだから
私は食べてみたんだから
で 他の人に言っても まあそうですかと
そこですぐ納得いく そっちそれは簡単に破れるんです
例えば 私はある音楽を聴いたとする
すごく気持ちよかったとする
で 私はみんなにあれは気持ちいいですよ
聴いてみてください 何でしょうかと
私は聴いたんだからと
私は何言ってるんですか？というと
私は聞いたんだから 私の気持ちよかったんだから
それで万人も森羅万象にしても
それは事実ですよと もっと失礼に言うならば
私に美味しいんだからあなたにも美味しいですよという
あれほど失礼な言葉がありますか？世の中で
だったらもうクマさんにも同じこと言えるでしょうに
ハイエナさんにも同じこと言えるでしょうに
ハイエナが腐っている
死んでいる動物の肉を食べて
ものすごく唾 よだれ垂らしながら食べてるでしょうに
だからハイエナが出てきて
これは美味しいんだから食べなさいと人間に言うとする
ということと同じなんです
でも我々はそういう世界に来ているんです
私は見たんだから うん
うん 綺麗でした 私は聞いたんだから
主観的なんですね 結局実際どういうものかとわからない
例えばラーメンって あの店のラーメンはすごい美味しいんですよと
人に頭に叩き込んでみてください
マインドコントロールしてみてください
で 店に行ってね お塩ももう足らない
もういい加減あちこちから拾って
何かでスープを作ってラーメン作ってあげたら
それでも美味しいでしょうに
マインドコントロールされたら
だからそこら辺はこの我々の仏の修行の道で
悟りの道では そういうところからまずマインドコントロール片っ端から壊す
それからじわじわと主観を壊す
主観は間違っているんだと
まあそうかはっきりとは言いにくいんだけど
主観は主観であると それは普遍的な真理ではありませんと
そこで主観なぜ生まれるかというと
ここに私がいるんだという錯覚なんです
それはその錯覚なんです
それは構成されているものなんです
そこでこの実践方法といって厳しい苦行をさせているわけでもないんです
いろんな仕来りやらせているわけでもないんです
特別な食べ物 特別な服
特別な生き方 何一つもさせてないんです
ただ簡単単純に主観を客観に変えてみようと
頼んでいるのはただそれだけなんです
例えば怒ったら 正当化させてはいけませんしね
怒るのは当たり前だと
あるいは逆に怒って いけない
いけない 私は本当に何でいつでもそっちを怒るんですか？と言って自分を責めることも意味意味がないんだと
どちらでも主観的なんです
怒って正当化することも主観的であって
俺自分の意見だから怒って正しかったと
あるいは怒って ああ いけないよ
なんで私はそっちを怒るんですかと自分を責めることも自分の主観でしょうし
それで我々は言うのは
怒ったら怒りですと 自分の心の状況を確認してみてくださいと
それは客観的な見方なんですね
だから試しにやってみたら
瞬時に怒りが飛んでいっちゃうでしょうに
消えるでしょうに どんなものであろうとも悩む必要なくなっちゃうんです
客観的に確認した瞬間で
そこはその問題は解決する
そこでどんどん心を変えて
主観的な心を客観的な立場に入れ替えちゃうんです
でもそれは 1 日にでは無理なんです
なぜならば 体を持って眼耳鼻舌身を持って生きているんだから
目で見るものは頭の中で
脳細胞の中で構成しちゃう
見たものと違うものを見えてしまう
全部頭の中の幻覚だから
音楽は聞こえるわけじゃないんです
聞こえるのは単なる音だけなんですけど
でも頭の中で音楽や雑音やとかいろいろ判断したり
だからその機能はそのままだから
そんな簡単に 1 日にして主観的な立場から客観的な立場に変わったということはないんです
もし変わったならば 例えば私の話を聞いただけでも
よし わかった 客観的だと心が変わったならば
それ悟りなんです その人に何の問題もないんです
ですから このなかなか
例えば子供のことも やっぱり客観
子供を育てた方が見た方がよく育てますよと言っても
スイスイやっぱり主観的になっちゃうでしょうね
例えば客観的にご飯を食べると
決して食べ過ぎにはならないんです
体に悪いものも食べないんです
それでも あ 美味しいやと思った途端
もうケーキ一つ余分に食べちゃう
だからすぐスイもう主観に行っちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 人がものすごくそこを客観的な見方
客観的な認識の訓練してしていく途中で
ある日いきなりやっぱり物事はそんなことだよと
その主観的なレベルから客観的な方向に心が変わっちゃうんですね
ここに私が見る 私が聞くという私がいないんだと
ただ聞く機能があって
そこで知識が生まれてくるだけであって
そこでこちらの欲やら怒りやら生まれるだけで
こういうプロセスだよと
もし音さえ変えれば その怒りも欲も生まれてこないんだと
例えば こちらに何か光があって
見えるものがあるんだと
それ目に入ったら 頭の中でそれをプロセスして
何色でしたっけ？視覚が生まれるんだと
その視覚に過ぎて ああ
綺麗だ 好きやとか あるいは汚いんだ
嫌だとかね どっちが感情生まれるんだと
綺麗だ 好きだと思ったってのも
見る対象ほんのちょっと変わったら
もうすぐ全部ずっと変わってしまっちゃうんじゃないかと
ただそれだけですよと
とわかることは悟りの第1番目なんです
それはこのヨルカと読むんですね
普通はソーターパティと読むんです
もうもう客観的な世界に入りましたと
ソータっていうのは流れ
アパティっていうのは入ったと
もう賢者の世界に入りましたと
入り口 それでその人のソーターパティというステージになった人は
自分という実体 変化しない実体
いわゆるこの主観の偉大なる主観の世界を作る創造者ですか
それ自分だから で 私が見たんだからという私がいるでしょうに
私が聞いたんだからと
やっぱり大事な自分があるという
これ自体が問題でしたと
本当はなかったんだと
単なる目から入る情報
耳から入る情報 脳細胞から入る情報
体から入る情報 それで幻覚としてプロセスしただけで
これは止まることなくプロセスしていくんだと
絶えずことなく 絶えずずっとその認識の主観の過程が起きているんだから
いつでも主観で そこで自分がいるんだという誤解だけでしたということに目覚めるんです
この目覚めと目覚めることは
もうヨルカと読むんです
すごくこのもうやりやすいんですよ
ただ客観的にものを見る訓練をするだけなんです
で 難しいところは 客観的に見ようとすると主観的な見方が来て攻撃する
また見ようとすると主観的な見方が来て攻撃する
そこはご自分の戦争で
私がやることじゃない
自分の頭の中で起こる戦争だから
一人一人で その戦争で戦わなくちゃいけないんです
いくら痛みが生まれても
痛み 痛みと見てくださいと
僕はいろいろ調べると
まあ痛い痛いと言ったんだけどと
はっ 呆れたと思っちゃうんですね
あれほど言うのに 痛み
痛みと確認しなさいと
結局痛い痛いと それだけでもものすごい勘違いでしょうに
耳に入るものは音を音だと確認してくださいと言ったら
車の音 宣伝車の音と確認
ちゃんと確認しましたと
だからやっぱり主観が出てきて攻撃してもう負けているんですね
それである人がね やっぱりきれいな鳥の声が耳に入って
ものすごく楽しかったと
で そこで何が悪いんですかと
別に何が悪いわけじゃなくて
もう主観的に成り済ましているでしょうに
だから悪いんです そんな調子だったら
もう悟りっていうのは無限大まで伸びちゃうんです
とにかく納得いかなくても
言う通りに確認してみてください
それ 言ってることは変なことじゃないんだから
音ですから なんで音だけで納得いかないんですか？耳に入るのは
損しましたと思うでしょうに
弟だと言ったら人の話はわからなくなっちゃうんだと
すごく損しましたと 逆でしょうに
人の話わかったんだからでしょうに
損しているのは だから我々教える側にしても
これ大変な苦しい嫌な仕事なんですね
この主観を客観に変えることは
だからといって何もしてあげることはできない
悪口ぐらいでしょうね
いわゆる だから この人を馬鹿にするということは
本当にこの失礼な気持ちでやっているわけじゃないんです
このいわゆるこの主観を叩いているだけなんです
すごい主観でプライドも持ってるでしょう
だから ひどいことを言われたら
ものすごく痛く感じるんですね
だからそこは狙いなんです
こちらの だからあまり人気のある宗教にはならないんです
私も失礼だとは知ってるんだけど
その調子も変えたくはないんです
変えちゃったら 何なる何のこともない生ぬるい説法になるだけなんです
あのお釈迦様のあの迫力のある聞いて悟ったというぐらい
あの力がなくなっちゃうんですね
だから失礼ということは十分知ってますけど
じゃあ丁寧に使用して
私はどうすればいいんですか？皆様の笑顔を
どんどん膨らますことでしょうに
そこはできません 壊すんだから壊さなくてはならないんです
ある限り苦しみなんです
そこで一応こうやって見ていると
自分というものはないということがわかってきて
ああ なんのこともないんだと
こんな苦しみなんかはもうまあ馬鹿げた話だと
すごく楽になるんです
そこは専門用語で有身見という煩悩が消えたというんですね
どなたか知ってる方がいてください
漢字はパーリ語でサッカーディッティというのです
サっていうのは実体として変化しない個体的な自分がいるんだと
という気持ちが客観的なプロセスによって
ああ そんなことないという事実に目が覚める
日本語でこれ有身見 漢字何でしたっけ？ん
むちゃくちゃだから誰が書いて
そこであの余計な話なんですけど
それしゃぶっちゃうんです
そんなに不思議なことでは
ないんです そのポイントで宗教は終わっちゃうんです
なぜならば 宗教の世界というのは
偉大なる尊い魂を霊を
大事に育てることでしょう
だから仏教の世界はもうはっきり言えば反宗教的なんです
いわゆる実践は宗教かもしれませんだけど
社会的な面で見れば 仏教も他の宗教と同じ宗教なんですけど
この悟りの境地っていうのは違うもので
結局この精神ですよ 魂ですよ
自分ですよと 尊い命ですよとかというふうな
このそんなことを思ったら
それを守らなくちゃいけない
例えば自殺したくても
尊い命はと言ったら自殺できないでしょうに
自由ができなくなっちゃうんです
どっちでも どっちにいたっても
まあとにかく無神圏で
この別に単なる科学的な宇宙の法則と同じく
もう現れて消えている法則だよということをわかったら
結局消えてしまう それと一緒に宗教に対するもうことを消えちゃう
それは次の煩悩で書いているんですね
あの なんとか シーラッブとパラマサというパーリ語なんですけど
全部もう書きたくはないんです
で いろんなこの儀式 儀礼
戒律 行 物に耐えること
拝むこと お祈りすること
ああいうことでは真理はわかりませんと
すべて主観的だから自由になっちゃうんです
それは回向衆と何とかとか書きたいんですけどね
いわゆる儀式 式だり いろんなものに頼ったことで
おジュースを持って帰らせることやらいろいろお鈴を鳴らすこと
いろいろあるでしょうに
太鼓叩くとかね 太鼓叩いたっても客観的にはなりませんと
で 自由になる それからこのもう疑いが消えちゃう
答え論消えちゃったんだから
私は何者ですか？という質問に即答えなんです
単なるものの流れですよと
だから疑問消える  1番目の悟りステージで
で そこで 2番目っていうのは何でやりますかというと
一応 もうわかったんだけど
それでも人間として生きているんだから
美味しい食べ物は美味しいし
美味しくないものは美味しくないし
まあ人々を自分にいろんな迷惑をかけたり
あちこちいろんなトラブル作っちゃった
まあ嫌ですね この人々
あんまり激しい怒りとか難題ということはないんだけど
本当にもう嫌ですよって気持ちは普通生まれるし
で そういうこと同時に楽しみという欲というものもあるんですね
だからまあ無常ですけど
まあそれでも楽しく生きたいという怒りと欲がそれでも残っているんです
さらに客観的になると
そこは薄くなっていっちゃうんです
薄くなった状態で まあ怒り必要欲
欲張り必要何もないんだということで
2番目と 3番目の悟りが成り立つんです
それもう一つがあります
ということは まだ足らないんですよ
この主観性を そこでこの現象は生き続く必要さえないんだと
瞬間の稲妻のようなものだから
一切無常だから という
ものすごい厳密に無常というものを体験すると
瞬間ということ そこでまあ誰にも迷惑をかけてない
楽だからね 生きていたってもいいんじゃないかという気持ちさえも消えてしまうことは
最終的な悟りなんです
すごいレベル高いんです
ものすごい厳密に もう徹底的に主観
客観的になるということは
主観そのものはないということなんです
いわゆる自分が消えることなんです
体が消えるということじゃないんだけど
自分という感覚がもうなくなっちゃうんです
それでも行動的なんですよ
ものすごい行動的なんです
例えば もう自分というものは邪魔になるでしょう
何かしましょうと思ったら
自分を守りに入るでしょうに
例えば宗教を喋る場合でも
みんなすごい人気が出てきて
みんなに慕われたら大変いいなと思ったら
ろくに話せないでしょうに
守る自分がなければ 人が怒ろうが判断しようが関係なく事実を喋られます
例えば 政治の世界の例を言いますけど
政治の世界にしても いろんなこと見えてるんですよ
中にいるんだから あれは悪い
これは良くないとかね
でも喋れないでしょうに
公で ...例えば二人が一緒に政治やってます
なさってますけど 一人がいろいろちょっといけないことをやっているのが見えるんだと
言えないんですね いろんな条件があって
言ったら自分の身が危ないと
そうやって自分を守るということは
いや 結構ハンディなんです
だから心の中の問題で
それは 自分というこの言葉をもう消しゴムで消してしまえば
すごく自由というものを味わえますから
そこは結構時間かかります
早くできるのは この預流果というところに悟ることなんです
だから預流果 二番目は一来果と呼ぶんです
三番目は不還果と呼ぶんです
四番目は阿羅漢果と呼ぶんです
そうやって順番があります
で 明確に説明欲しいと思うならば
まあ次の講演会で まあ本当は一回一回が終了ということにして話してます
それは長い時間 ありがとうございました